Voilà où je veux en venir :
ceci est l'image la plus utilisée, recherchée et partagée
de tout mon travail pour l'instant.
Et je pense qu'il y a une raison précise,
ou du moins, je l'espère.
J’espère vraiment que les gens commencent à comprendre
que lorsqu'on pense à l'environnement et à la destruction de la nature,
on se doit aussi de commencer à penser aux océans, également.
Depuis la création de ces sites, nous avons observé
des résultats phénoménaux et inattendus.
Outre la création de plus de 800 m² de nouveaux habitats et récifs vivants,
maintenant les visiteurs du parc marin de Cancun partagent leur temps
entre le musée et les récifs naturels,
donnant un repos important aux zones naturelles surexploitées.
Des visiteurs d' « Océan Atlas » au Bahamas ont mis en lumière une fuite,
provenant d'une raffinerie voisine.
Par la suite les médias internationaux ont forcé le gouvernement local
à investir 10 millions de dollars dans le nettoyage des côtes.
Le parc de sculptures de Grenade a joué un rôle
dans la désignation par le gouvernement d'une zone marine protégée.
Les tickets pour le parc alimentent un fonds d'aide pour les gardes-côtes
afin de gérer le tourisme et les quotas de pêche.
Le site a été cité comme « Merveille du monde »
par le National Geographic.
Alors pourquoi sommes-nous tous ici dans cette pièce ?
Qu'avons-nous tous en commun ?
Je pense que nous partageons
tous une peur :
nous ne protégeons pas assez les océans.
Et une bonne façon de le voir
est que nous ne considérons pas nos océans comme sacrés
et nous le devrions.
Quand on regarde des endroits incroyables,
comme l’Himalaya, ou la Sagrada Familia,
ou même la Joconde,
quand on regarde ces incroyables endroits et créations,
nous comprenons leur importance.
Nous les considérons comme sacrés,
et faisons de notre mieux pour les chérir, les protéger
et les garder en sécurité.
Mais pour faire cela,
nous sommes ceux qui doivent assigner cette valeur ;
autrement, ça sera profané
par quelqu'un qui ne comprend pas cette valeur.
Donc je veux conclure ce soir en parlant des choses sacrées.
Quand nous nommions le site à Cancun,
nous l'avons appelé musée pour une simple et importante raison :
les musées sont des endroits de préservation,
de conservation et d'éducation.
C'est un endroit où nous gardons les objets de grande valeur,
où nous les chérissons pour ce qu'ils sont.
Si quelqu'un jetait un œuf sur la Chapelle Sixtine,
nous serions tous outrés.
Si quelqu'un voulait construire un hôtel 5 étoiles
au pied du Grand Canyon,
on leur rirait au nez.
Et pourtant, tous les jours nous polluons et surexploitons nos océans.
Et je pense que c'est plus facile pour nous de faire ça,
parce que lorsqu'on voit un océan,
on ne voit pas le ravage que l'on crée.
Parce que pour la plupart des gens,
l'océan est comme ça.
Et c'est vraiment dur
de penser que quelque chose de si plat et de si énorme, est si fragile.
C'est simplement trop massif, trop vaste, trop infini.
Et qu'est-ce que vous voyez là ?
Je pense que la plupart des gens regardent par delà l'horizon.
Je pense donc qu'il y a un danger réel
que nous ne voyions jamais vraiment la mer,
et si on ne la voit pas,
si elle n'a pas sa propre iconographie,
si on manque sa majesté,
alors il y a un gros danger qu'on la prenne pour éternelle.
Cancun est connu pour les vacances de printemps,
la tequila et les soirées mousse.
Et ses eaux sont où les bandes de mecs peuvent faire des tours de jetski
et de bateau banane.
Mais, grâce à notre travail là-bas, il y a maintenant un petit coin de Cancun
qui est très précieux pour ce qu'il représente.
Et on ne veut pas s’arrêter à Grenade,
à Cancun ou aux Bahamas.
Juste le mois dernier, j'ai installé ces Quatre Cavaliers de l'Apocalypse
dans la Tamise,
au centre de Londres, juste devant la Chambre du Parlement,
mettant un message puissant sur le réchauffement climatique
devant les personnes ayant le pouvoir de changer ces choses.
Parce que pour moi, c'est juste le début de la mission.
On veut faire équipe avec d'autres innovateurs,
créateurs, philanthropes, éducateurs, biologistes,
pour imaginer un futur meilleur pour nos océans.
On veut voir par-delà la sculpture,
par-delà l'art, même.
Disons que vous êtes un citadin de 14 ans,
et vous n'avez jamais vu l'océan.
Et plutôt que d'être emmené au musée d'histoire naturelle
ou à un aquarium,
on vous emmène voir l'océan,
pour voir une Arche de Noé sous-marine,
à laquelle vous pouvez accéder à travers un tunnel de verre,
où vous pouvez voir toute la faune de la Terre
être colonisée par toute la faune de l'océan.
Évidemment, ça vous couperait le souffle.
Donc pensons grand et pensons profondément.
Qui sait jusqu'où notre imagination et notre volonté peut nous mener ?
J'espère qu'en amenant notre art dans l'océan,
on bénéficie non seulement de sa créativité spectaculaire,
et de l'impact visuel de la scène,
mais qu'on comprend aussi quelque chose,
en encourageant l'environnement à prospérer,
et d'une certaine façon,
ouvrir une nouvelle, ou peut-être une très vielle façon,
de voir la mer :
comme des endroits précieux et fragiles,
dignes de notre protection.
Nos océans sont sacrés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)